de l'eau des centaines de milliers de
tonnes d'eau repose gelé et sur les
montagnes du monde pourrait penser que
cet endroit est l'un des moins propices
à la vie aucune végétation de poule sur
ses champs de neige
ceux ci n'y a pas de végétation et donc
pas de nourriture
il ne peut y avoir non plus d'animaux
tels que marmotte fourie ou la pas et il
n'ya pas d'herbivores il ne peut y avoir
deux carnivores aucun prédateur tels que
faucons de l'être en fait il existe ici
une quantité surprenante de vie une
forme de vie qui existe à l'intérieur du
champ de neige lui même parce que cette
neige n'est pas blanche et les rouges
cette couleur provient d'algues
microscopiques
elle est provoquée par la lumière qui se
réfléchit sur les parois de leur cellule
ce qui est pratiquement invisible
lorsqu'on les examine au microscope
intérieurement elles sont vertes par la
présence de chlorophylle grâce à
laquelle elle utilise l'énergie solaire
pour transformer le dioxyde de carbone
et l'eau en sucre ces substances ainsi
que les minéraux dissous dans la nasse
fondante apporte aux halles de tous les
éléments nécessaires à leur survie et à
leur reproduction
les lourdes chutes de neige de l'hiver
les enfouir on faisait une couche de
plusieurs mètres mais au printemps
lorsque la surface de cette couche font
les algues se divise on développe deux
petits fils grâce auquel elles
rejoignent la surface et la lumière du
soleil en vieillissant alors que les
minéraux s'amenuisent elle change de
couleur formant des normes taches rouges
sur les champs de neige
il n'est pas facile pour les plantes de
pousser sur les pentes escarpées le
passage continuelle de la douceur
relative du jour aux gelées de la nuit
fait que le terrain caillouteux émouvant
et peu propice à la fixation des plantes
en conséquence les animaux herbivores
sont rares
ces animaux dans les montagnes de
l'himalaya sont des moutons bleu ou
barral leur agilité les rend capables
d'accéder à la végétation de ces
falaises
s'ils sont peu nombreux
plus rares encore sont les animaux qui
pourraient en faire leur propre durant
l'été le léopard des neiges a été vu à
5400 mètres d'altitude
mais lorsque ya l'hiver il est contraint
de se retirer dans les vallées le gibier
est maintenant si rare qu'il y en a tout
juste assez même sur un vaste territoire
pour nourrir un seul léopard aussi cet
animal et qui est un chasseur solitaire
les grandes montagnes d'amérique du sud
volcaniques pour certaines telles le
cotopaxi 5900 mètres d'altitude font
partie d'une chaîne qui parcourt toute
la longueur du continent entouré par de
vastes plaines froide l'altiplano les
versants de ces montagnes abrite une
population vaste et varié d'animaux
adapté à la vie en haute altitude et aux
basses températures
ici vite la vigogne c'est une sorte de
chameaux sauvages
son pelage soyeux la protège
efficacement du froid or c'est lui
paradoxalement qui a conduit la vigogne
à une disparition presque totale car
l'homme
la chasse est intensément pour l'intérêt
que représentait cette laine superbe la
population des andes domestique et un
autre chameaux sauvages le guanaco qui
non seulement les propres aussi une
excellente l'homme mais lui sert
également de bêtes de trait en équateur
et au pérou près de la ligne quoi
taurian ces animaux vivent jusqu'à plus
de 4000 mètres d'altitude
plus au sud en patagonie et en terre de
feu le guanaco vie par contre presque au
niveau de la mer il y développe un
pelage tout aussi épais car l'hiver la
terre ici est complètement couverte de
neige et les états eux mêmes sont
extrêmement froid
cette rigueur de la température qui
augmente à mesure que l'on s'approche du
pôle est quasi à comprendre à l'équateur
les rayons du soleil frappent le globe
perpendiculairement si on suit la courbe
arrondi de la terre plus on se dirige
vers les pôles plublique l impact de ces
rayons solaires sur la surface de la
planète au paul
leur effet donc répartis sur une surface
plus grande et ils doivent en outre
traversé une couche atmosphérique plus
épaisses aussi de la terre baignée par
les eaux glacées au large du cap horn
une chaîne de petites îles volcaniques
s'échelonne jusqu'au continent
antarctique archipel du bout du monde
paysages grandioses et désolé des îles
sandwich du sud et des orcades du sud
seuls deux variétés de plants de la
fleur peuvent survivre ici et on n'y
trouve aucune trace d'un animal
terrestre
par contre les mousses et lichens
prolifèrent certains sont capables de
survivre gelé pendant plusieurs semaines
s'alimentant sur eux une ménagerie de
minuscules animaux créature primitive à
peine plus grande que des têtes
d'épinglés résistant au froid les plus
intenses grâce au fait que leur sang
contient une sorte d'anti gel qui lui
permet de rester liquide
même lorsque le thermomètre plonge bien
en dessous de zéro
les maires entourant saisi l'antarctique
sont parsemés de blocs d'eau de mer
gelée en hiver ces blocs de glace vont
jusqu'à former une couche solide à la
surface de l'eau les icebergs sont d'une
autre nature
ce sont des blocs d'eau douce détaché du
bord de la banquise derrière la banquise
on découvre la masse du continent
antarctique
si le sol est stérile les eaux
environnantes sont au contraire
particulièrement fertile ainsi la vie
prolifèrent sur les bords du continent
et plus encore sur les plages des îles
au large c'est le royaume des otaries à
fourrure et des lions de mer qui se
nourrissent de bandes crevettes leur
épaisse fourrure conserver leur et leur
offre une isolation thermique lorsqu'ils
nagent
les plus grands les éléphants de mer ont
un système d'isolation différents tout
leur corps est entouré d'une épaisse
couche de graisse qui leur permet de se
nourrir en eaux plus froides et plus
profondes
chaque année à l'époque de la mue ils
perdent cette capacité ils se
rassemblent alors sur les plages et se
blottissent les uns contre les autres
pour se tenir au chaud
si vous aviez à désigner un animal qui
symbolisent les étendues glaciales de
l'antarctique vous en choisir y est sans
doute un du genre de celui ci un gourou
doré ou man show macaronis nous sommes
sur l'île de géorgie du sud à mi chemin
entre la terre de feu et l'antarctique
en fait il semble qu'à l'origine le
manchot évoluer dans des climats moins
froid aujourd'hui encore certaines
espèces vivent proche de l'équateur aux
îles galapagos leurs manteaux isolant de
plumes très dense qui leur permettent à
nager au chaud sous toutes les latitudes
leur faire maintenant contre les vents
froids de l'antarctique
lorsqu'il se tiennent debout sur terre
ou sur un iceberg
ce sont de superbes nageurs non
seulement ils sont rapides et agiles et
dans l'eau mais lorsqu'ils arrivent à
terre poussé par des vagues déferlantes
qui écraserait n'importe quel bateau il
semble avoir l'élasticité une balle en
caoutchouc
ces manchots à jugulaire mesure environ
60 à 70 cm le manchot royal lui mesure
près d'un mètre
une grande taille constitue un avantage
sous les climats froids plus grands ils
corps plus petit et la surface de peau
par rapport au volume un grand manchots
retient donc mieux la chaleur corporelle
qu'un petit
c'est en hiver que naissent les petits
du manchot empereur stoïquement planté
sur la glace pendant deux mois
les mâles seul un cube les eaux jusqu'à
ce que les femelles reviennent de la mer
avec leur estomac rempli afin de nourrir
les nouveau nés
ensuite c'est chacun à leur tour que les
parents iront jusqu'à la mer pour
apporter de la nourriture à leurs jeunes
mais maintenant que l'hiver touche à sa
fin la mer est gelé sur une vaste
étendue et les manchots de remarcher
parfois 80 km pour atteindre l'eau les
adultes ont un instinct parental très
développé ceux qui ont perdu un petit
tenteront d'adopter un poussin et
d'autres iront même jusqu'à et cube est
un morceau de glace
tant que les poussins portent leurs
duvets ils dépendent entièrement des
parents sans leurs primes âge d'adultes
ils sont incapables de nager et donc de
se nourrir eux mêmes à la sab le mans
les parents vont fouiller leur propre
estomac pour y trouver de quoi rassasier
leur petit perpétuellement affamés
semaine après semaine ils effectueront
leur longue marche jusqu'à la mer en
quête de nourriture
ce n'est que huit mois après leur
naissance que les jeunes auront enfin
leur plumage définitif alors toute la
communauté on ira vers la mer qui à
nouveau avec le printemps et la débâcle
des glaces est tout proche
contrairement à l'antarctique qui est à
continent isolés par la mer l'arctique
englobe des régions terrestre d'amérique
d'asie et d'europe
de sorte que des animaux d'europe et
d'amérique du nord ont pu rejoindre
cette partie gelée de la terre la
coloniser et s'adapter à ces exigences
particulières ainsi le renard de
l'arctique dont le pelage est plus léger
que celui de son cousin du sud et qui
devient complètement blanc en hiver
la banquise est aussi le terrain de
chasse de l'un des plus grands
carnivores au monde
l'ours polaire qui est un lien de
parenté évident avec ses congénères
d'europe et d'amérique
sa couleur blanche est évidemment une
adaptation à la couleur du paysage
ambiant et sa taille beaucoup plus
grande que celle de ses cousins des
régions tempérées qui est une fois
encore au fait qu'un grand cor retient
plus aisément la chaleur qu'un petit
lorsque l'on s'éloigne du pôle la terre
se réchauffe suffisamment pour n'être
plus recouverte que partiellement par la
neige et la glace c'est la toundra
paysage de marécages des temps de galets
de pierres et de gravier ou la vie
pendant la courte période de l'été
présente une surprenante variété de
petites fleurs poussent au ras du sol où
le vent se fait à peine sentir et ne
perturbent pas l'effet du soleil dans
des terriers peu profonds habitent les
moissonneurs de cette maigre récolte de
feuilles d'herbe les mines
durant l'été quand sa nourriture abonde
cet animal se reproduire vitesse
stupéfiante
la femelle peut mettre bas cinq à six
petits par portée et cela quatre à cinq
fois en une seule saison
cette prolifération attire bien entendu
des chasseurs comme le harfang des
neiges une sorte de chouettes dont le
lemming constituent la nourriture
principale
à mesure que les jours à l'ange des
hordes le caribou arrive en provenance
du cid accompagnés de leurs petits mais
plus tôt dans la saison
ils doivent se déplacer constamment afin
de couvrir leurs besoins en nourriture
et parcourra si jusqu'à 25 km par jour
les oies des neiges sont également
arrivées certaines de région si
lointaine que le mexique distant de près
de 5000 kilomètres pour se partager la
riche moisson de secours étaient et pour
donner naissance à leurs petits
il en existe deux variétés la première à
des plumes sombres la seconde des plumes
toute blanche
rapidement la toundra se couvre de leur
nid les oies des neiges font bientôt
attaquer par des nuées de moustiques
car de semmar chaude et klose des
myriades d'un insecte vorace jusqu'à
100000 au mètre carré en une saison
à leur tour ils constituent ici la
nourriture d'une folle a rope à bec et 3
des larves de mouches noires qui ont
passé tout l'hiver agrippé au fond de la
mare peu profondes commencent à émerger
le foisonnement de la vie est à présent
intense car la lumière est pratiquement
constante 24 heures sur 24
arrive la fin du mois d'août l'oie des
neiges la première récent l'imminence de
l'hiver et reprend le chemin du sud les
caribous à leur tour reviennent sur
leurs pas à travers la toundra en
continuant à se gaver de nourriture afin
de se constituer la réserve de grâce qui
leur permettra de passer l'hiver au fur
et à mesure que le temps se refroidit le
besoin de trouver un abri se fait plus
pressant et les troupeaux parcours
maintenant jusqu'à 40 km en une seule
journée
finalement les voyageurs sur le chemin
du retour atteindront les premiers
grands arbres la vaste forêt de
conifères qui s'étend au sud de la
toundra tout autour du globe
c'est le sanctuaire qui les protège de
lilas glacial